(cris de la foule)
des slogans à la gloire du pays,
au caù certains en
douteraient, Kharkiv est
ukrainienne. La deuxième ville
majoritairement russophone, veut
envoyer un message clair en ces
temps troubles, la Russie n'a
pas d'alliés
Sur scène, le discours passe
patriotisme aux appels à se
tenir prêts à défendre la ville.
- Nous ne paniquons pas,
nous nous préparons.
Gloire à la nation.
- Celui qui chauffe la foule,
Cet ultranationaliste dirige
la cellule kieieieienne du
corps national, une organisation
d'extrême droite.
dededede la foule)
Il croit que l'Etat uenenenenes
assez vite pour préparer
le pays à affronter la menace
de la Russie voisine.
KONSTANTIN NEMITCHEV, chef org.
- Malheureusement,
le genenenenent n'en fait pas
assez. Les gens ne savent pas
où trouver un abri. Ils nee e es
doivent prendre avec eux. Il n'y
a aucune information.
Alors nous rassemblons ces
défenseurs ckikikikikikikikikiks
d'informer les gens.
- Pourtant, il y a moins de deux
semaines, le présidentrnrnrnrnrs
projecteurs sur la ville de
Kharkiv en déclarant,
en entrevue au Washington Post,
qusisisisisisisisisisisisisisis.
Un choc pour beaucoup ici.
BORIS SEVASTYANOV, chanteur
- Quand le président Zelensky
a déclununununununununununununus
étaient certainement inquiets.
Mais étonnamment, contrairement
à 2014 où ils étaient absolument
personne ne savait quoi faire.
Et les forces ,,,,,,
la police de l'armée et
du SBU étaient toutes en train
de s'effondrer. Maintenant,
Kharkiv est dans une situation
complètet t t t t t t t t t t ts
en forme.
- En 2014, des séparatistes
prorusses ont marché dansséséséé
industriel. Brièvement,
ils ont hissé le drapeau russe
sur cet édifice du gouvernement
régional. vivivivivivivivivivivt
de Lougansk dans le Donbass,
ils ont été rapidement chassés
de la ville par les forces
ukrainiennes. L'épisode
a marqué un véritable tournant
Êtes-vous une personne qui
veut krkrkrkrkrkrkrainien dans
une Ukraine unie, ou êtes-vous
une personne qui veut que
♪ ♪ ♪
- Boris Sevastyanov a eu
deux réponses à
identitaire en 2014. D'abord,
il a pris les armes pour
il a cessé de parler le russe,
nanananananananatale, publiquem.
Avant de nous rencontrer,
le chanteur populaire n'lelelele
en russe. S'il fait exception
aujourd'hui, c'est pour
faciliter la conversation.
- L'une e e e e e e e la guerre,
pas la principale, mais c'était
supposément la protection de
J'ai donc pensé que j'avaisbebee
cette tendance à parler russe
pour être n'n'n'n'n'n'n'n'n'n'ne
la langue russe. Je la parle
depuis ma naissance, mais
je crois que c'est important
la langue ukrainienne.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Aujourd'hui, c'est avec
les Russes. Des mots acerbes,
crusdédédédédédédédédépourvus
d'une certaine ironie.
♪ ♪ ♪
Sa récente chanson,n n n n n ns
tout près de la frontière,
promet de faire des so
d'aventure, il revenait
en Ukraine.
La guerre, on ne veut pas trop
le moins possible au marché de
Barabbas Chauveau, avec ses
le long d'allées entrecroisés, s
d'Europe de l'Est.
Ioulia dehahahahahahahahahahaud
chez elle, à la retraite,
dit-elle. Mais elle n'a pas
ici pour vendre du thé etioioio,
nous avoue Tania, visiblement
bouleversée par l'id
- On ne sait pas qui souhaite
On ne sait pas comment c'est
possible. J'ai de la f
là-bas. Comment je vais
prendre les armes et les tuer?
me tuer? Et puis quoi encore?
t t t t t t t t t t t une telle
douleur que quelqu'un qui
pense ça n'a aucun parent
- rerererererererererere que
c'est à la Russie d'assumer
le r é é é é é é é é é é é é é e
fait partie d'elle.
Elle coule dans ses veines.
Mais visiblement, tout le monde
russe, n'est pas du même avis.
- Mykola Grouchko a été soldat
jojojojojojojojojojojojojojojojt
de parachutistes en territ
ennemi sont bien loin derrière
lui. Mais il se dit prêt à
si nécessaire.
♪ ♪ ♪t mort
de toute façon, dit-il,
philosophe.
Autant le faire debout